TAKAKO AIKAWA: So
the development
of speaking and listening
requires interactions
with somebody else.
So that has to be
done in classroom
because there are not so many
Japanese people on campus
at MIT.
So classroom activities really
focus on the development
of listening and speaking.
Whereas reading and
writing, students
can do them outside of class.
And then, in
particular, our textbook
has a so-called workbook.
And then they can do writing
practice by themselves.
In fact, we provide assignments
so that they can just
practice writing at home.
For reading, our textbook
has a reading section
for each lesson.
And we provide a
reading session one day
for each lesson in class.